Dr. Zakia,
no introduction to such a topic would be
complete without you defining the terms.
So could you firstly define the term
Ramadan?
>> Alhamdulillah.
The word Ramadan is derived from the
Arabic word ramida or Ramad which means
intense scorching heat and dryness. It's
also derived from the Arabic word ramda
which means sunbaked sand. In Islamic
terminology, the word Ramadan it
signifies the intense heat in the
stomach due to thirst.
When a Muslim fasts the thirst that is
there, it produces heat in the stomach
which is defined as Ramadan. Again
Ramadan
it has another meaning. It means that
the good deeds they scorch the sins and
the evil of a Muslim. So Ramadan is a
month in which the sins are scorched
away by the good deeds like how a sun
scorches the ground in the same way and
heat normally it helps in forming,
molding or reshaping
virtually every matter. In the same way,
Ramadan helps in molding, shaping and
reforming the spiritual and the moral
aspects of the human being. That is the
reason we term this word Aramda.